[Music]
CTM in focus is original reporting
you'll see only on CBS this morning
exposing new information on issues that
impact us all this morning we focus on a
growing backlog at crime labs nationwide
that's leaving victims waiting for
justice a recent government report found
that backlog for DNA analysis increased
almost 85 percent from 2011 through 2017
Mireya Villarreal got a rare look inside
the Arkansas state lab and spoke to one
woman stuck behind bars because of the
backlog Maria what else did you learn
well good morning you know we met a
woman in that was actually in a Georgia
jail for about three months for
possession of cotton candy police
thought it was meth and now she's suing
her attorney says this was an injustice
that was created by a crime lab backlog
that could affect anyone out there on
New Year's Eve 2016 deja Fincher was on
her way to a pawn shop in Macon Georgia
with her boyfriend when they got pulled
over were you nervous at all no no
because we wouldn't do anything wrong
dashcam video shows the pair calm and
cooperative so when was the moment that
things changed when he come out to back
things said what is this in this bag it
was a bag of cotton candy
Fincher said it was left in the car on a
humid night turning the fluffy treat
into blue crystals results from a
roadside test kit identified it as meth
I couldn't believe it I wanted to cry
but I was like this would be over in a
minute he over in a minute
I really didn't even think I would even
go to jail less than eight minutes later
she was in handcuffs charged with
possession of methamphetamine with
intent to distribute it still sits with
you it does her bond was set at 1
million dollars an amount she couldn't
even come close to pain so she sat in
jail for three months telling them to
please please calm down and do something
you wanted to get out of there yes it's
been it's been two years and I still get
upset about it was it the hardest time
in your life it was I missed a lot
desperate to get out fincher consider
taking a deal before her evidence was
even tested by the crime lab her
attorney James Freeman says in Georgia
that
steam process could take at least three
months so there is a chance innocent
people are taking these plea deals just
to get out of jail it's not just a
chance it's a fact
Fincher passed on taking that deal and
was eventually released when the lab
results came back negative for any
illegal drugs so the backlog isn't just
about cases like daesh's it's not just
drug cases it's not just accused
criminals
it's everything that needs to be tested
by the crime lab but Georgia isn't the
only state facing a growing crime lab
backlog CBS News has uncovered dozens of
states are significantly behind Illinois
has a backlog of more than 23,000 cases
in South Carolina it could take more
than nine months to get results back on
DNA or Firearms testing in Idaho some
cases have been pending for almost two
years
is there a backlog here in Arkansas oh
absolutely
this is all evidence that's waiting to
go home Arkansas crime lab director
Kermit channel says the problem
escalated about six years ago coinciding
with the rise of the opioid crisis in
his lab alone DNA and drug cases have
nearly doubled since 2014 they are more
complex and if we talk about a drug case
it's not simple marijuana it's
methamphetamine its fentanyl it's heroin
this is this where it all happened this
is the laboratories where we have almost
twenty eight chemistry we were given
rare access inside Arkansas's crime lab
where scientists carefully test each
piece of evidence
it's a painstakingly meticulous process
I can smell the evidence in here you can
downstairs is where all the evidence is
stored each of these boxes holds
essential evidence inside them important
for a case and in drug cases alone there
are 23,000 of them coming through the
Arkansas crime lab a year so in Arkansas
I could take over 150 days to possibly
get that case in a position where they
could take it to a grand jury or get an
indictment yeah absolutely you know that
and that's concerning this isn't just an
Arkansas problem oh absolutely not I
mean this is this is a national epidemic
so Arkansas is crime lab actually our
Arkansas governor approved more
funding for their crime lab and the
state will actually open up a new lab in
July that should help it's closely
working with prosecutors to close out
cases where a deal has been made and
they are now farming out some of this
testing to private labs because they
just can't handle this backlog
themselves the number of people in
America not convicted of a crime but
still sitting in jail is appalling that
is exactly what is happening here and
not in all cases obviously but but but
clearly they're trying to clear this
backlog in the prosecution part of this
and also in the evidence part of this I
can't imagine what Daisha went through
with a million dollar bond on obvious
when she obviously couldn't pay she was
stuck you you say she really did almost
consider that deal she really she knew
she was innocent it was blue it was blue
cotton candy obviously and she just
wanted to get out she was so scared of
being in jail she's like I'll just I'll
just take this deal and that's what I
keep focusing on - Anthony is daesh's
story because it's all it's all kind of
levels of wrong number one I don't
understand why the bond is set at a
million dollars for that infraction you
know a lot of that had to do with the
intent to distribute and because it was
the amount that they claimed they
thought it was of meth and so that's a
big problem but you know a lot of people
talk about the rape kit backlog this is
a byproduct that is a byproduct of what
we are seeing in these crime labs around
the country very important story very
good didn't have you have the table and
see you in person I know thanks Maria
said in the green room look I'm wearing
girl pants in real
[Laughter]